we are rolling
we have speed
we have a mark
action
the doctor said we could stay here in
the chapel and talk
okay
sure
what are we gonna do
I don't know
it's not fair
none of it
that poor little thing
you know it has a heart
is beating
right
how can that be
how could it have such a tiny healthy
heart
that everything else be so
maybe it's not for us to understand uh
we understand well enough
it is what it is
it's got multiple birth defects that's
what the doctor said please don't call
her it
she has a name
Melanie
she's a human being
she's alive
she belongs to you and to me that's not
true
she does belong to me nor do you either
she is no part of us
what do you think those doctors can do
with surgery
make her a whole person from a sort of
parts
you're mistaken even think that they
can't do a damn thing
the doctor said a decision must be made
now
oh God oh God Is Right
you're the one who believes in all that
crap
so tell me
what does your God tell you to do now
to keep her alive and to take care of
her forever it's been seven days today
it's appropriate to me that on the
seventh day
your God rested so
today is resting where
going fishing out to lunch be back in an
hour
but you get the bastard back here
because I want to talk to him now
don't
don't talk like that
I think God's fault whose fault is it
it's not for us to understand whose
fault is it
my yours it isn't anybody's fault I
don't accept that
please
you know maybe maybe we shouldn't have
used birth control pills maybe you
shouldn't have experimented drugs back
in your college days
you heard me
are you blaming me
are you saying that this is my fault
you did drugs too back then maybe it's
your fault I need to know why I'm baby
I was born like this
it's God's will
we must accept that
she's a special baby there are special
schools oh no no no no
stink
you know what honest to Christ they gave
us the wrong one
can't deal with this
serious
I cannot handle this for the rest of my
life
you know what
I refuse to be responsible for the
saying nobody can make me
but Melanie is our responsibility
she's all we have
and we're going to tell the doctor to do
the operation
to do everything in his power to give
her the best possible chance in this
world serious what chances I have just
what
no no no
we are not going to we have to no we
don't have to and we won't it's not fair
to
her
shouldn't asked to be born
we wanted her
and we're going to tell the doctor to do
everything that he can
I love her and I don't care what you say
she has just as much a right to live as
you do
and we're going to tell him to do what
he can
no we won't
because if I have to
I'll stop her living myself
and damn you
no you won't
couldn't do that
God will give us the strength no shut up
shut up
I've heard all I want to hear about your
absentee God it does not exist
speak
please
please please please please let us help
her
all right wait all right it'll it'll be
all right okay I promise you
promise it'll be all right okay just we
we all right we will talk to the doctor
again okay
let's please
please please don't Don't Cry Anymore
and cut
that's all right
nice work okay
uh yeah
yeah you have a slow roll Slow Burn okay
you know but that's okay if that's the
way you felt like doing it that's the
way you do it you know
Jack Nicholson says if you get a feeling
go with it
you know if it's not right that the
Articles they take do
pretty simple
you know pretty simple everything we're
doing here is simple guys you're just
not easy
you know this process is simple simple
simple simple simple lovely work good
for both of you thank you okay
ready to do it again
yeah change it up it's up to you change
it up I don't want to give you a
redirect because there's no reason to if
there is something that wasn't working
I'd tell you but it's working so if it
ain't broke don't fix it
you know let go a little more be a
little Freer with her
you know I feel you hold them back a
little bit
don't hold back
all right
we're rolling
sound is speeding
we have a mark
whenever you're ready
the doctor said we go stay in the chapel
and talk
okay
sure
what are we gonna do
I don't know
it's not fair is it
a poor little thing
it has a heart
it's beating I mean how can that be
how can it have such a tiny healthy
heart
and everything else be so just
maybe it's not for us to understand we
understand it well enough
it is what it is
it's got multiple birth defects
that's what the doctor said
please don't call her eight
she has a name
Melanie
she's a human being she's alive
and she belongs to you and me
that's not true
she doesn't belong to me
what are you either
part of us
what do you think those doctors can do
with surgery make her a whole person
from assorted parts
didn't mistake it if you think that they
can't do a damn thing
well they said a decision must be made
now
okay oh God Is Right you believe in all
that crap
what does your God tell you to do now
to keep her alive
and to take care of her
in seven days today
it seems appropriate to me that on the
seven day your God rested
so today is resting resting where
going fishing out to lunch back an hour
is that what he's doing well you get the
basket back here right now because I
want to talk to him right now
don't
don't talk like that this is not God's
fault whose fault is it
maybe we don't understand no no whose
fault is it tell me mine yours what this
isn't anybody's fault I do not accept
that
please
all right maybe
maybe we we shouldn't have used birth
control pills no maybe you shouldn't
have done all the experimentation with
drugs during your college days
what you heard me
are you blaming me
are you saying that this is my fault
you took drugs too back then maybe it's
your fault no I need to know right now
why our baby is born like this it's
God's will
so well what you're going to tell me now
we will grow up and we'll take you to
some kind of well those special schools
or something like that no no no I don't
want to hear it
is all a mistake it's just a big mistake
honestly Christ you know they just gave
us the wrong one that's what it is
I can't deal with this
I'm serious
I can't handle this for the rest of my
life
you know what
I refuse to be responsible for this
nobody can make me
but we are responsible for Melanie
we are all she has
and we're going to tell the doctor to do
the operation
we're going to tell him to do everything
in his power to give her the best
possible chances chance for what what
chance does it have no no no no
we're not going to we have to no we
don't have to and we're not going to
it's not fair to it
she didn't ask to be born
we wanted her
I love her
and I don't care what you say she has as
much a right to live as you do
so we're going to tell him to do
whatever he can no we won't
and if I have to
I will stop reliving myself damn you
no you won't
I didn't do that
God will give us the strength no no no
I've heard all I want to hear about your
absentee God
exist stop it
stop it
God is that special little baby
God is you and me and our little girl
please just let them help her
all right
it'll be all right
it'll be all right we'll we'll go ahead
we'll talk to the doctors now okay
please
right or okay
we'll be all right
all right we'll talk to dogs again
good good good stay up there guy you're
gonna do it again oh okay got another
one in you so yeah yeah good good light
nice for y'all good for you